take a look at buehler his career
against the san diego padres 5-0 and a
1-6-6 he already making his career-high
30-second start
has a chance to get a career-high 15th
victory
and also has a chance for 200 strikeouts
he needs four more
he swings at the first pitch and flies
it to right mookie betts
makes the catch one pitch and one away
and this ball game is underway
sending home the payoff pitch
and he got him swinging just a fastball
to 95 and
tatis with a weak swing
ground ball to short senior will go the
short way trey turner
will put out on the four sound
dodgers coming to bat against you
darvish
on the mount for san diego is you
darvish 35 year old veteran making his
30th start fifth time this season
against the dodgers
opponents on the year hitting 219 we've
seen you darvish when he's really really
good at times he's kind of faltered a
little bit
in the third and he's pitched
one down to third that's a fair ball
brookie's gonna round first head for
second
and he's got a hustle he will get in
before the throw of the pop-up slide and
a lead-off double for mookie betts
[Applause]
coming war through short right field and
a rising fastball to strike him out
so sugar strikes out first down here in
the bottom of the first inning for la
darvish will now face trey turner starts
the night 3 22
0-2
and this ball
left center field that's gonna split the
outfielders and go to the wall mookie
around third he'll score and in the
second with a run scoring double is trey
turner one nothing dodgers
the o2 pitch
driven to deep center field back goes
grisham to make the catch
shy of the warning track again to end
the inning dodgers get a run lead at one
nothing after one
right off the fists in a one hopper for
seeger
and a one two three top of the second
inning for walker bueller
hey gavin lifts this one into left
center field that's a base hit
[Applause]
deluxe continuing to swing it
one out now two on
fly ball
center field trent grisham in a few
steps
we'll make the catch and the dodgers
leave them loaded
we play two it's one nothing la
one two
strike three carratini is swinging and
missing
second strikeout for bueller
here's the one two on the way and
darvish strikes out
two down
[Music]
two strikes two out nobody on third
inning
frazier with a ground ball to short easy
play for seeger throws to first easy
inning for bueller
the runs though hits no errors and
nobody left through three
bueller has given up one walk and that's
it
that's a
great stab by tatis throw off the mark
and that
is going to be a base runner for the
dodgers
will smith fly to center field in his
first at-bat
2-2
and it's it sharply down to third
machado will throw from one knee and he
still gets it there in time fires it
across in time what a play two down
spectacular play by the gold glove third
baseman aj pollock up he struck out
swinging in the second
justin takes off this ball is hit into
the gate trey turner will score justin
turner is going to get held at third
and aj pollock with a two-out run
scoring single and the dodgers have a
two-nothing
the
lead
swung on and missed strike three tatis
down on strikes
and for bueller that's his fourth
strikeout of the game
dealers wind in the o2
they got him looking
strikeout number 201 on the season and
number five tonight
ground ball to short good hop for seeger
three up three down once again for
walker bueller
oh wow thank you
straight through to seeger
swinging a mess and turner strikes out
back-to-back case for darvish six and
all done with four it's two-nothing la
chopped by the mound incoming is seeger
his throw is late
is your first hit of the ball game for
the padres infield hit for eric osmer
and he hits it down to third turner's
got it he goes to second trey the turn
got it around the horn double play
to shallow left and frazier makes his
way in to make the catch that will end
the inning
dodgers strand two more we head to the
six two nothing la
victor caratini grounds went through the
left side into left field a base hit
starts things here in the sixth inning
ground ball down to third turner's got
it to turner one on to first
double play
second time tonight the dodgers have
gone around the horn this one ends the
inning
two nothing dodgers
[Music]
trey turner has three hits in the ball
game
i would have to say scherzer this is
down the line and into left field the
two up base hit eric hosmer he's
thinking two throw to second he's going
to be
safe eluded the tag somehow osmer's
smelling too
does the matrix
swimming
this is awesome let's check it out lift
the arm over the tag
walker bueller making his 32nd start of
the year he was terrific tonight no runs
three hits five strikeouts two walks 90
pitches didn't give up a base hit until
the fifth inning
went down in the ninth inning and it
brings up jay cronenworth
in the air to deep right field that goes
bets looking up and that ball is
gone home run jay cronenworth it's his
21st of the year the padres cut the lead
in half not going quietly in the ninth
inning and the tying run is aboard for
the padres tommy fam will come to bat
two ball two strike pitch
[Applause]
strike three
the dodgers have won seven in a row
against the padres
[Music]
[Applause]